house minority leader kevin mccarthy
along with house speaker nancy pelosi
were the only two leaders to receive a
classified intel briefing
by the fbi on eric swalwell and china
as well on russia kevin mccarthy joins
me right now and congressman good
morning to you it's great to have you
here
good morning maria so you've said that
eric swalwell should step off of the
intel committee you received this fbi
briefing
as well as nancy pelosi so you both
heard the same thing
do you think she would agree that
swalwell should step down
well you are right that friday we
finally got our fbi briefing it was just
the speaker nancy pelosi and myself
it was a very thorough briefing no one
that was in that room could walk out and
say eric swalwell should be on the intel
committee i don't know they had a
briefing before in 2015
and i don't know what that briefing was
like compared to this one but it could
not have been the same
the one answer that i got out of that
briefing was there
is no way eric swalwell should continue
to serve on the intel committee
and the challenge here is the leaders of
both parties are the only people
who select to go on the intel committee
that is why today maria what i'm going
to request
that every single member on the house
intelligence committee gets the exact
same briefing from the fbi that i did
because if this individual is sitting on
this committee eric swalwell
they've got to know the background of
what has gone on
i can't talk about the classified part
but you know what's out there in the
press
this is an individual maria you've done
this more than probably any other show
the in-depthness of what china has done
the number of hacks
of stealing the the top secret items
from the f-35 from our missiles going to
the opm
taking more than 24 million names but
what they have done is so far now when
you see this christina
that she went down low as the mayor she
went down to know
eric swalwell as a city councilman
helped him to get to congress
and continued and tried to put interns
in his office this is so concerning and
then
as a very junior member just in his
second term he gets named to the intel
committee
and that exact same year when the fbi
came to brief
the intel committee because they were
concerned of what they saw
he gets put as the ranking democrat over
the cia
i do not understand how this has
continued this long
and the first time i've heard about it i
got a briefing on it was friday and i
would never
never allow him on that committee
unbelievable so just based on some of
the things that are out there that are
public i recognize you can't release
what you heard in terms of
what's classified but what we know is
that the fbi
went to him to eric swalwood and said
watch this woman meaning the fbi
must have been watching christine fang
yeah if you the one thing you can read
publicly it wasn't swalwell going to the
fbi it was the fbi
coming to swalwell and to the leaders to
warn what they have
noticed also remember in the public
briefing what you've
able to find out about christina eric
swall was it wasn't the only individual
there are mayors
involved across this country this is how
in-depth the chinese are
at spying on america of wanting to know
of stealing our secrets
and the intel committee is different
than any other committee this is where
america's secrets are kept
this is where the individuals are able
to know things that other members are
not
and as a member of the gang of eight and
john radcliffe has talked about this
the gates reports that i'm able to read
anybody that sits and is allowed to read
those gates reports
inside the intel committee would know
the expansion of what china
is doing in america today
i want to zero in on california as well
because i know that dianne feinstein
had a driver had a body man whatever you
want to call it for 20 years
and after 20 years of this chinese
national working with her
we find out he's a spy so there were
pictures we've been showing pictures of
christine fang
with eric swalwell but this area in
california around silicon valley
it looks like the chinese communist
party really tried to exploit
dianne feinstein eric swalwell we know
nancy pelosi's district is there
adam schiff's district is there so let
me ask you about that
because there is a picture that we found
with
this woman christine fong in the same
picture as the spy
that was with dianne feinstein is this
all connected congressman
this is very concerning to me because
you've got to understand silicon valley
the brain trust of america
think of all the innovation that happens
there now we have a u.s senator
not for a short time period but for 20
years the person here that could hear
all of her phone calls know where she
drives understand her entire schedule
listen to the most sensitive phone calls
was a chinese spy
and he was in a picture with christine
feng who the fbi says was a spy who left
this country
and the thing this is why this is so
much bigger than eric swalwell
this comes into question about the
democratic party themselves
do you know we tried to put a bipartisan
task force on china last year
with all the threats with the virus
going on the democrats backed out the
night before we were to announce it
you got adam schiff who is the head of
the intel committee
when we shut the consulate down in
houston for the chinese
because they're spying he said that was
just escalation
our adam schiff who's in charge of the
armed services
on the house floor he said it was not
china's responsibility to warn us about
the virus
this is a concern to me that goes be if
you vote for nancy pelosi
for speaker you willingly know that
she's the one that has the power to put
eric swab on the house intel committee i
think you should have that answer before
you make that vote
and when is china when is china going to
wake up
they know the communist party is coming
in and hacking america time and again
they know there are adversaries but why
won't they stand
up to them and if you can't stand up to
them
how can you put somebody who could have
been jeopardized on the intel committee
you know the difference part is this is
it that remember what they did to
president trump or to his family
or they did to the attorney general if
somebody walked by and talked to you
this is an individual that publicly
reported has been friends with him for
years who bundled money for him
who advised him who tried to put interns
in his office
this isn't somebody walked up and got a
picture with you
well this is this is china's candidate
there's obviously china put him there
let me ask you before i move on to
stimulus real quick is nancy pelosi
compromised by the chinese communist
party
well i don't know about that but the one
thing i would know that
nancy pelosi needs to do she's the only
decision maker and whether eric swalwell
stays on the committee or not
she got the exact same briefing that i
got it is clear it's without a doubt
wow i would never put him on that
committee and i would remove him today
this is dangerous stuff
very dangerous stuff and the world
should really uh understand this because
the chinese communist party has already
said
they want to be the number one
superpower in the world overtaking
america economically technologically and
militarily
the world should not want that real
quick on stimulus congressman you are
working on the
final version of what could uh be
something signed into law
when what what is in this plan and do
you have optimism
that it will pass i do have optimism
that has passed the optimism is let's
get it done
um you know speaker pelosi finally
admitted after the election that she
held up to cause more pain
to try to make an outcome of the
election that this whole time when we
could have had
some covert relief to the american
people for those who are unemployed
for the number of small businesses that
were out of work i am very hopeful that
we get this done today
this will go out for the small business
owner and their employees
more than 300 billion dollars in ppp
this could help
our ability for tax incentives to help
the small business
restaurants um there's so much in this
bill that could help us
and the unique part about this is we're
able to rescind the money
in the carriage package before that we
appropriated that we're not spent
so we're being fiscally smart and also
very smart about helping the american
public in this economy
in the end of the year so real real
quick you're talking about aid for
restaurants aid for the airlines
as well and you don't have in their
liability protection
and you don't have in their aid for
these states correct
yeah i i i would i we need liability
protection
unfortunately the democrats will not
allow that to happen you know the trial
lawyers are very strong with the
democrats
and so the state money should stay out
along with the liability protection and
we need to come back and solve that
um these small businesses already
hurting they won't be able to sustain
themselves even if they're able to get
up and running
if we don't get them liability
protection
okay so that'll be that'll be a separate
separate package then real quick before
you go congressman you got the uh
you you got the covet vaccine right how
are you how are you doing how do you
feel
i feel good yes i just got it uh friday
um a number of us i think everybody in
congress and the supreme court and
others
for continuity of government i feel good
it was a
easy process but most importantly we
have a safe and effective vaccine
that we need to thank the president
trump for that he did something
that nobody else has been able to do
moderna is now moving out a second
vaccine
not only will we be able to cure this
virus
remember where it came from and remember
who solved the problem
all right congressman it's good to see
this morning a lot of breaking news this
morning from